thank you
the roller conveyor
the humpback heart
the wheel of death
[Music]
those are just a few of the 37
attractions at the amusement park iprp
Italian for under the poplars
and it was all built by this man
stretch your legs out in front of you
straighten them out yes that's it
otherwise you'll land with your nose on
the rubber okay
Bruno Bruno is 85 years old he built his
first swing here half a century ago
it's always a joy to come here and see
what I've built up in 50 years it's a
great feeling to be able to say about
your own life I made all my dreams come
true imagine that
[Applause]
his dream began with a restaurant in
1969. Bruno Farin fell in love with this
piece of forest as his wife served wine
and sausages under the poplars he
started building swings he taught
himself everything
[Music]
I only ever went to elementary school
but I've always understood numbers
It comes naturally to me working out
weights and counterweights for my
attractions
of course I make mistakes at times and
have to adjust the rides that they're
too heavy or if the slope isn't right
what's special about Bruno's Park is
that none of the attractions require
electricity they use the laws of physics
and the muscle power of visitors
the newest attraction is the carousel he
had the idea for it after watching a TV
report about a training facility for
NASA astronauts
this Carousel is powered by these
bicycles operated by visitors when you
pedal the carousel spins
the faster it spins the more the
centrifugal force increases causing the
seed frames to move backwards from the
center
[Music]
okay
while other amusement parks face closure
due to Rising electricity costs Bruno
Farin is forging ahead and planning for
the Future
[Music]
Energy prices are through the roof so
I'm thinking of installing dynamos on
every ride to harness the energy from
all the equipment moving around that's
my plan
applied on a large scale that idea would
foil the strategies of some world
leaders
wouldn't be very happy at a park like
mine because of everything worked like
this he could no longer sell gas to
Italy yeah
there have been no accidents in the
decades-long history of his Park Bruno
Farin says nothing escapes him
sit down young man come on
you need to sit down because it's
dangerous
[Applause]
you see they don't read the signs that's
how Italians are
in Germany signs are law but here in
Italy they're optional maybe I'll read
them maybe not
that's how it works in Italy
around 50 000 visitors come to the park
every year it's open only on weekends
and entry is free Bruno Farin believes
it shouldn't matter how much money you
have everyone should have the right to
have fun
when I do my accounting at the end of
the year if I'm left with even one Euro
of profit then I'm happy
not everybody understands this concept
but it works for me
most visitors buy something to eat and
drink in his restaurant making the
business sustainable
even at 85 he's still pitching in
everywhere he can
he says the freedom to do what he loves
has kept him Young
it's a beautiful way to live depending
on my mood each day I decide what to do
isn't that great my dears that's the
Poetry of life
one that he's devoted to his amusement
park
[Music]